we need three screens you know it
actually is a very interesting approach
it looks great from what I've seen on
the note 4 has that little screen on the
side so you actually get a little added
bit of information when you look at it
from an angle so you know how about just
help me visualize this for a second
since that when you when you look
directly at your screen you see some
information if you kind of look at it
from the side you can see little folders
and other information so you really do
get you get an enhanced experience I
think it looks great if they can pull it
off this might be something that gets
people to you know could make Samsung
hot again front on the smartphone so you
don't find yourself like trying to lean
over and say okay what is on that side
screen you just kind of turned your
device a little bit but it actually
what's important right now all
smartphones really look the same
everything's are rectangular brick with
about the same thickness the question is
what can be done to differentiate and
this is Samsung's really the only guy
that's trying to do something new and
you know some guys are doing curved the
whole screen is curved so this is new
they're they're throwing something at
the wall to see what sticks we'll see if
it's successful